hey if you lose is the one percent rule
if you got one drop of that loser blood
in you then you're a loser bro it's
facts bro yeah he's half uh european
defense white half uh maori samoan
now shout to izzy
izzy uh
another victory another notch on the
belt there are some lunatics out there
that are saying that they think that uh
robert whittaker won the fight he fought
much better than the first time
of course but i think what's happening
with izzy is like he's so dominant that
you start looking for rounds for his
opponent yeah right this is the
mayweather thing that happened where
it's just like he's just kicking ass
every single time so if the opponent
lands a decent strike you're like oh
that's a big [ __ ] deal
no
yeah izzy beat him convincingly four out
of the five rounds not even close
and uh you could give him maybe one
round but i thought the way the refs had
it was pretty good and izzy's just the
[ __ ] best bro it's crazy yeah
actually the ufc needs to start building
up another fighter so there's someone
for him to fight
yeah i think that's what the ufc needs
to do a better job who is it right now
if there was he's going to fight
cannoneer probably because canonier just
finished brunson but like
they need to build up another [ __ ]
guy because izzy's not leaving
middleweight most likely so if he's just
gonna wipe through the division once
again we're just gonna see another
robert whitaker fight probably soon i
don't need to see that fight again these
fights when the guys are more evenly
matched can be more technical and
they're not as interesting i like seeing
izzy bounce people's heads off the
[ __ ] canvas that [ __ ] is fun paula
costa coming in talking all that [ __ ]
and just getting [ __ ] knocked out and
then humped
that was fire
give me the young [ __ ] talking guys he
ended that guy bro game over the guy
couldn't the guy was 20 pounds
overweight for his next fight jesus
taught me how he drove too much wine
yeah
he went bald afterwards yeah he broke
literally lost his hair afterwards broke
him yeah literally yeah that's
unbelievable and he got like a hair
transplant had to take time off because
of it yes broke that man so it's um yeah
it's [ __ ] tricky man it's tricky he
needs an opponent and when you're the
ufc
you
have all the guys uh
under contract right so it is your
responsibility to build up these other
guys granted the guys that make the
biggest name for themselves end up
getting the fights but it's like yo
get some [ __ ] editors on some clips
or something yeah like i i need somebody
else to build this fight up besides izzy
we need somebody out there that we're
going oh my god can that person beat him
who else is out there can you guys say
it um
that's a problem i'm looking to use the
greatest mma journalist of allah i am
sean but he's 135 pounds he's never
gonna yeah what's no chance what is his
next
he'll fight canon and then he'll
probably have to fight uh guys that he's
already fought in the division again or
there'll be guys that come up and wait
but the next interesting fight which
won't happen because both of them said
they won't do it would be kamara usman
coming up and wait um to fight izzy but
they're brothers they just won't do it
yeah um
and then
i mean they both said that they'd rather
you know two nigerian champs than than
one yeah double division champ or
something like that uh there's this
other guy
uh hamza chimayov you guys heard about
him he's like super highly touted and
he's this guy he's got uh amazing
wrestling but he's also got good
kickboxing so
there's something interesting there
and uh but they got to build him up and
then there's another guy the perrier
pereira whatever like that this is a
dude that uh actually beat izzy when
they fought on the kickboxing match
earlier and he just entered the ufc and
i'm not even sure if he entered at
middleweight but that'd obviously be a
match that people are excited by because
they're like oh [ __ ] this guy beat izzy
this guy beat izzy we got to see if izzy
wants to run it back yeah so those are
the guys but those guys that just named
are all two or three fights minimum away
from a fight with izzy
is it worth talking about jon jones
no because john is
adding weight and then moving up to uh
heavyweight yeah and izzy posted the
funniest [ __ ] [ __ ] about him did you
see this no oh my god he posted a
picture of of
jon jones i don't even think it's john
jones i think he's just a guy but he
posted this on twitter yeah of uh of a
guy wrapping his hands with the wraps
and um the caption was jon jones
wrapping up
a valentine's day gift for his fiancee
jon jones wrapping a valentine's day
gift for his fiancee
because he beats up his wife a lot
allegedly
but not so allegedly yeah but yeah i
mean brilliant he's just the best at
troll so it's like
jon jones don't want that for and the
[ __ ] he said about rogan was dope too
yeah super brave again yeah mic drop
that's my [ __ ] guy there's a lot of
clutch in his business
and this guy's a real one he's been
nothing but nice to me yeah
that [ __ ] was fire for him to say that's
my n word is bold as [ __ ] that was
especially in that situation you just
dropped it
but yeah i mean honestly we need
somebody else in the division with some
[ __ ] charm dude
and i'm fine with is he busting his ass
but we need other people to believe that
this guy has a chance to beat izzy yeah
and that's what's going to make the
biggest fight
because otherwise it's going to be a
situation where izzy's got to promote
the whole thing by himself
so these guys in the division got to
look and see what izzy's doing and then
start copying that [ __ ] in their own
[ __ ] way here izzy how many more
fights are you thinking about before i'm
getting out of the game saving my brain
saving my body that's a great question
dude
that's a great question i mean if i'm
him
because he could do he could transition
to whatever he wants career-wise that's
the thing i'm most curious about this
with him is just like do you feel like
you're missing out on opportunities by
living in [ __ ] new zealand
because if you live
what's that then you say he was leaving
yeah you leave but then they decided not
to go okay and he's loyal to the boxing
club right because they're a team and
they're all like bringing each other up
and it's a beautiful thing to see but
please believe if he was living in los
angeles he'd be in every marvel movie
yeah
there's so many different opportunities
that hit now
you also have to look at these things
and the grass is always greener you
might have all these opportunities but
you might get shittier training you
might have guys that are willing to die
for you and you might not be as
successful fighting right and i think a
lot of times especially people in our
industry they look at what they could
have right this always happens with
agencies and that kind of stuff and all
the agencies have hit me up hey come to
us we're going to give you this we're
going to give you guys agent putting the
press on you
[ __ ] it was so funny where is this uh it
was after a show in miami and this is
how loyal andrew is he's so loyal to our
guy who he got me he said yeah i'll join
your agency just hire my guy and the guy
legit for 30 minutes kept trying to
get andrew over and he's like look i
will come all you have to do is hire my
guy and the guy just wouldn't do it yeah
yeah that's true because like that guy
built something with us yeah right shout
outs to tj it's like tj build something
with us and it's very hard for me to not
be loyal to someone who's been loyal to
me i'm probably loyal to a fault yes are
there other opportunities that i could
get at these other agencies 100
without a doubt massive things but then
there also could be things that hurt me
and we got a great thing cooking over
here yeah and i like being loyal to my
guys and building with my guys because
at the end of the day that's more
fruitful and those guys wanted nothing
to do with you when you didn't have
anything exactly tj stuck with you 100
yeah 100 and was part of building all
this so that always going to get
rewarded right uh for me and i and i
hope that you know i imagine izzy
probably feels the same way yeah like
yeah it'd be nice to be in these movies
but at the same time like these guys are
also responsible for all the things
that
that he's created
you know and uh
yeah i don't know for me that's very
important the crew is very important
that's why i roll so deep
you know
like
everybody's everybody when we go to
places like everybody goes yeah and it's
because everybody's responsible and
the success that i have in giving me
opportunities to do these things you
know what i mean yeah so is it a pain in
the ass for the ufc when we're going to
go to ufc fight and i say yeah i need
six tickets yeah yeah you know the elk
boys get four
right all right you know what i'm saying
like but
it took six of us to
for them to reach out and want me to be
there yeah i said i learned that's why i
flew kevin and duchar out for rogan you
should have uh y'all ain't gonna be
allowed in the studio but i got rogan
you all helped me make this special more
than anybody so you're coming down 100
we'll figure out we'll go celebrate
after but you're coming yeah 100 that's
the way to do it so hopefully as he's
feeling a similar way
you